but this would be a cultural solution
something that i mean we've all
advocated uh trump should have done when
when he was president he should have
just signed up for he should have signed
up for gab i think he should have he
should have put his posts on gab that
would have sent a huge message to the
mainstream media
he didn't do it no
i i can respect let's also say maybe it
had to do with the staff because i can
tell you now
people think that people like president
trump or people like me or someone else
that people like and and politics they
think that we have all day long and we
control all of it we don't i mean we
can't who can do everything
this is why when i asked about
censorship i you know i said can you
even do anything right because i i kind
of i'm going to tell you no because i'm
going to be really honest right here i'm
going to tell you something i got really
angry because i got disappointed in
republicans that's why i ran for
congress i was like republicans didn't
do anything they told me they were going
to do on the campaign trail they very
much disappointed me
and when i saw republicans fail when we
had a republican president the white
house
republican-controlled uh house of
representatives and a
republican-controlled senate that was
from in 27 and 2018 and they didn't
repeal
obamacare i'm sorry if you support that
they didn't repeal it but that took my
family's health insurance premiums from
eight hundred dollars a month to over
twenty four hundred dollars a month i
was really upset that the republicans
who said they were gonna do something
about it did nothing about it and then i
cared about border security and they
didn't build the wall they didn't even
fund it and i was like wait a minute you
guys all ran for congress on this stuff
and i think there's a lot we need to do
about immigration and i don't always
agree with all the things that have been
thrown out there but they didn't do
anything and i'm very pro-life i'm i'm i
think abortion is terrible i i can't
even as a mom it's so sad to me that
women are sold a lie that they that they
have to have an abortion in order to
have a professional career or to to have
value in any way i think motherhood's
the greatest way to have value but
republicans did nothing so my point is
this going back to censorship no i don't
trust congress to fix it i don't that's
why i'm telling you i believe in the
american people i believe in starting
new companies i believe in starting new
platforms and i believe the people can
solve the problem because we still have
the freedom and the ability to do it the
challenges
with parlor and gab really good examples
uh gab was smeared relentlessly
relentlessly by the press then they had
their infrastructure attacked by silicon
valley parlor was the exact same thing
they lied about them and then the these
big tech companies used the fake news as
a pretext to go after the infrastructure
right you want to know why
why is that their competition
but right so so put twitter and facebook
out of business this big tech lobby and
their the media collusion and they're
all working to support the democratic
establishment and to a certain extent
the republican establishment too not
republican outsiders oh yeah how can a
regular person start up a company and
i'll give a shout out to gab right
andrew thorpe the foundation is great
i'm on gab they're building their own
infrastructure god bless them but but
it's crazy that that's what you have to
do because all of these companies work
together to like they collude it's con
it's corporate communism i'm gonna go
back to it over and over let me let me
explain
i'm a small business owner that's what
i've always been it is really hard to
compete and bid on projects against big
companies because they have everything
set up so that that was hard for us for
a long time and then we had to work we
had to work harder than anyone to build
our company to a place where we were
like yeah we're landing these contracts
over and over because we've built a good
reputation we've built the um
relationships and we're able to do it
this is what this is what gab and getter
and and telegram and these other
companies are up against this is what
rumble is up against they're the little
guy that has just gotten in the pond and
these giant fish want to devour them and
they're so evil
here's what's really bad they collude
together this is why i call it corporate
communism i know it's a weird idea and
people aren't used to it but communism
is control it's control through
government and big corporations together
and they and they become this really
small elite at the top and everyone else
is these little fish down at the bottom
that can never rise to the level because
the media what did they do they totally
trashed uh parlor they totally trashed
gab and and tore them down and i think
they said there was like oh it's a
platform for white supremacist or
something like that um i i i agree with
you a lot i think it's a cultural uh
it's a cultural change that needs to
happen i think if trump was just in the
middle of his you know first term said
i'm going to go on gab or mines or
something then it would have forced the
media to do it that would have just put
a stake right to the heart of these
vampiric entities he didn't do it and so
perhaps it's just going to be we have to
build up confidence in in these other
platforms ourselves no matter no matter
how hard it's going to be problem is if
you have a platform it can ban you at
any time that's always going to be the
case and i agree with you i'm not big
government and for the government to say
you can't seems fascist so i like that
they're allowed to do whatever they want
but i think i have an idea that we can
toss around congress is that if we can
force free software code for social
networks that are super large basically
functioning as part of the commons so
that other people have access to the
software code and can start their own
uh website with that basically that same
technology is awesome with like the
analytics and the messaging and all that
and build their own terms of service on
their
version network communists
see i was going to say you guys believe
in limited government i believe in no
government but but we also have to admit
the fact that the government was
involved in building up big tech whether
it's q intel whether it's helping them
build infrastructure whether it's google
maps i say for me personally there is
action to take give it all back you took
it you took all the tax incentives you
took all the infrastructure you were
able to make leaps and bounds because of
your relationship with government it
ends now and i think if we just cut off
government from the private sector uh i
think that would be the most important
thing that we could we could do because
there is collusion there are a lot of
lobbyists and they're literally i think
working with intelligence agencies in
such a cohesive way that there's no
separating them from the state and
private entities there's it's nothing
different for me for my perspective this
is my new buddy for dinner on wednesday
night
chili cheese dogs
cheeseburgers let me ask you this uh as
it's campaign season i mean some people
have been campaigning
non-stop there's no i feel like that's
all we do is campaigning that's right
but they've just taken away
twitter is one of the biggest social
platforms in the world yeah is it it
when they say oh make your own twitter
that's like saying you have there's one
major football stadium of people where
everyone talks and they're going to tell
you to go to a high school you know
football field that that is
here's what i'm getting to
do you have any plans to go after
twitter for unfair election practice or
election interferences or unfair
practices as it pertains to giving your
opponents access to this network and
taking it away from you well i'm going
to say this because i'm still talking
with my attorneys everything's on the
table right now so i don't have an exact
um i can't lay out my exact plan because
obviously we everyone's just coming back
from the holidays
but i'm still in discussions with my
attorneys i think i have a lot of
options and i think twitter has a lot to
worry about um you know and here's why
i'm an elected member of congress and no
one elected twitter
and no one appointed them to be this god
of information and misinformation and so
for like dr malone which is really
shocking to me that he was
permanently banned you know i'm not a
doctor so i'm not going to get into the
science of of covered vaccines i don't
think it's appropriate to get into that
for me um but dr malone played a giant
role uh in the mrna technology for these
vaccines i would think his voice is
definitely more credible than twitter's
ability to judge if he's misinforming
the public about 19. isn't there a bit
of a contradiction i mean if if you feel
that the government can't solve this
problem
is you know filing a lawsuit to
challenge a private company's decision
to remove you the right path
no i definitely think i'm a big believer
so there's a difference there's a just
our justice system right so we're three
branches of government so you don't
always want to rely on the law making
body that's what i'm a member of
congress that's the law making body um
but the justice the justice system i
believe in and this is i mean this is
one of the reasons why i have really
gotten involved with the pre-trial
january 6 defendants not in their cases
because i'm very much against the riot
on january 6 but i've been very
concerned about how they've been treated
pre-trial because i believe in due
process but i believe in the ability to
take a case to court um and to say
here's where i've been wronged and to be
able to then defend myself and and have
necessary action taken oh wow that's
that's that's a great distinction
um yeah passing a law is very different
from having a court uphold say a
contract or a statement exactly
uh well i suppose it'll be interesting
to see what your your argument i'm you
said you have options on the table it'll
be interesting to see what you you end
up putting forward there's um
uh didn't dr robert malone say he was
going to be suing as well and um there's
a lot of people yeah it's not just
malone it's also mccullough it's also
robert kennedy jr it's also a hard swap
of other doctors that are getting hit
that are getting censored all over the
place whether it's instagram whether
it's youtube whether it's twitter slowly
but surely they're boiling the frog here
and trying to take away any kind of
dissenting voices creating more
establishment echo chambers and creating
a situation where even just looking in
the wrong direction or burping in the
wrong direction will get you
kicked out of normal society i think
this is all done in collusion with the
20 30 vision the kind of social credit
score and these these individuals are
working hand-in-hand with government and
i and i think
i agree with you the private kind of
solution is needed there more than ever
but i think the world the word needs to
get out there but how can the word get
get out there when it's being censored
and controlled on the information
highways by the people who built it so
that's that's such an interesting
paradox that's very difficult but this
is why i may agree with you i may
disagree with you it doesn't matter our
voice still should be heard no matter
what it is and the fact that it's being
censored is just atrocious and the fact
that it's being politicized in such way
it's so obvious what they're doing right
now and i i think we better wake up or
we're going to be boiling very soon and
i think the first bubbles have already
popped up and excuse me but i think
you're one of the big bubbles that came
up there you're making people realize
how hot the water is yeah they they ban
a sitting president
and trump was you know it was it was the
end of his first term so people said
well you know it's in his first term no
no you're
margery you're in congress right now
yeah and i have pulled my polling
numbers we just did them a few weeks ago
they're unbelievable i have so much
support in my district um
i think it was like 54
said they would elect me no matter who
ran against me
that's really high i had i have like a
70 71 or 72 percent um support rating
there hardly anyone elected has that
type of support so i'm not an outgoing
member of congress i'm very much a
supported member i mean even in that
capacity i mean you there's still
another year basically of you in
congress doing work right and you're
you're going to be affecting federal
laws
the people of every every state of every
city every citizen of this country they
need to know what you think and why you
think it and twitter decided to strip
that away from you
that i think is is you want to talk
about lawsuits you want to talk about
personal ethics or fairness all of that
aside twitter is is harming the united
states by doing this i think so too i
see it as a complete attack on our
government it's it's an attack it's not
only attacking our government it's an
attack on over 700 000 people that live
in georgia's 14th district that i'm
supposed to represent this is twitter is
acting as an enemy is it a complete
enemy to our american system everything
everything the way it's set up and again
i it's corporate communism i'll say it
over and over and over again this is not
how private companies should act think
about this any other private company
that attacked a a member of congress
let's say that i'm somewhere and someone
comes up and puts their hand over my
mouth
do you think that something's not going
to happen to them oh believe me they're
going to have serious consequences to
pay
twitter did that to me did you see the
uh
it's it gets brought up a lot because i
guess it was you know people like they
enjoyed it when i was on joe rogan's
podcast with jack dorsey yeah it was
great there was one really important
point i think the most important point
was when i mentioned to jack they have a
policy on misgendering that policy
is a leftist world view
half the country disagrees with it that
is twitter overtly saying
we will allow leftworldview and ban
right world view this is going to rip i
told him this in 2018 it was 2018 i
think i said if you keep doing this this
country is going to get ripped apart and
look look where look where we've got
where we've gone with you know people
being shot in the streets with with the
uh january 6 with just people in this
country are ready are right to explode
which is so sad because we really
shouldn't be look here's my thing i'm a
big believer there's only two genders
and i don't mean to offend anybody if
some some guy wants to run around in a
dress and he wants to call himself a
woman
that's his thing but i'm not going to
call him a woman because i think he's a
man and i don't think you should be
kicked off a twitter just because you
think there's only two genders and
you're kind of going along with what the
chromosomes say uh with gender and sex
but no you're right you can't just force
one world view or or one type of culture
or anything that's like saying oh you're
only allowed to be on this platform if
you're a christian well can you imagine
the outrage over that this is exactly
why i've always had a problem with it
when we had a fellow on the show i said
the problem i take with critical race
theory praxis in schools like actually
indoctrinating kids is i would take
issue with public schools teaching uh
telling a kid to you know pray the hail
mary five times or whatever if a public
school says we want you to do this
religious practice i'd be like hey you
can go to your you know private
religious practice for this critical
race theory this left world view is a
religion it's very much so so i take
issue with any kind of indoctrination
my view is let teach the kids let them
learn let them develop and think for
themselves teach them how to think
critically teach them history teach them
real history real history let them
figure it out you know give them
guidance but instead what we get are
people who simultaneously claim
that
you know what i'll just be reiterating
your point for twitter to say you have
to agree with our world view would be
like if twitter was a christian company
that made leftists agree with the
teachings of the bible or they'd be
banned absolutely that is a thousand
percent what it is they they believe
this on on what they have to say about
climate this is this is what they
enforce on on how they how what you're
allowed to say and what you're not
allowed to say or what's accepted speech
about gender um it's what is accepted
speech about say blm french incense what
is accepted to talk about january 6
twitter literally right now has
something set up for tomorrow for the
anniversary of january 6 for violence
that may be tweeted
so they're not they're only allowing one
view of january 6 and and not maybe
other stories or videos i mean think
about that what if people are wanting to
post their videos
and they're not going to allow it i also
believe there's an element of it that
that is something that is snobby elites
thinking that they could control what
you could listen to and i think that's
one of the most patronizing that's one
of the lowest level kind of thinking
individuals that you could have with
this larger idea that you yourself don't
have any discernment you don't have any
personal responsibility you need to be
told what you can and cannot listen to
that idea is absolutely absurd it's
criminal and and the fact that
individuals control what you could see
when they control the algorithms they
control people's perceptions they
control our views of the world and when
you control that you could control
almost everything and that's why
and the intelligence agencies have been
so involved with big tech and that's why
i i think there's even a bigger play
here that of course is snobby is very
elitist but it's essentially leading to
the divide and conquer agenda and trying
to control individuals by controlling
thoughts thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time